this is a production of Cornell
University
all right good afternoon I guess
everyone my name is Hannah sway garden I
am actually a PhD student in the section
of horticulture
however I am minoring in plant breeding
in food science and I wanted to come
here today to kind of talk to you about
a small little project that's well not
really so small anymore but involve of
trying to connect consumers and plant
breeders and I thought that an
imperative part of this project was that
I actually communicate and talk to plant
breeders as well which is why I'm here
today to give you a little bit of
background I work in a diversified
vegetable breeding program is based out
of Geneva I work with dr. Philip
Griffith who works with several
different crops including snap beans dry
beans small fruit tomatoes and many coal
crops including cabbage and broccoli
cauliflower and then as of recently
we've kind of been focusing a lot on the
leafy Brassica types which include kale
and collard types I'll just kind of give
you an example of the diversity we're
working with in the program we've kind
of taken some of the existing
morphologies and the leafy Brassica
types which include kind of like a
Collard or a Tuscan kale or a steep
curly kind of kale and really worked on
developing and enhancing the aesthetics
of these different leafy types which
includes the leaf shape the leaf colors
and leaf sizes and so as of right now
we've got an immense amount of diversity
that quite frankly we don't really know
what to do with and so that's kind of
where we sit and as a result we've kind
of taken an integrative approach since I
started almost two years ago now with
the program we've been working to
connect make connections with New York
City by performing chef's demonstrations
are working with green markets and some
of the farmers markets down in the city
we engage with lots of seed industry
partners trying to get feedback having
them come out through our field days and
communicating with them and then as of
the summer we'll begin some of our
on-farm trialing with some of these new
diversified leafy Brassica hybrids and
so as such I think we get a really good
perspective of kind of who we might be
interacting with across the food system
in our breeding program but when I first
started in fall of 2015 I
I did a lecture by New York Times
journalist Amy Harman and during that
lecture she made a call for scientists
who engage with the public in a more
empathetic discussion and I'm sure she
was referring to stem community at large
but as a horticultural plant breeder I
kind of went through some
self-reflection and really tried to
think about how I was engaging with the
public and how our program specifically
was engaging with the public and as such
I realized that there was really one
group that we don't directly connect
with all that often and that is in fact
a consumer while inherently I think we
understand as readers that our products
end up in the marketplace and are
consumed in some capacity we know we're
not always directly interacting with
them and the reason why I'm not entirely
sure is it that we viewed the volatility
of consumer feedback and market to crazy
to really kind of rap into something
that we can integrate into our breeding
program is it that we don't really know
what consumer or we think that we don't
know what consumers want or consumers
don't really know what they want do we
view this interaction with consumers is
too time-consuming do we not have the
time for it
are their language or translation
barriers between plant breeders and
consumers or is there just in a lack of
established methodology that can be used
to connect these two these two players
in the food system and while I said I
don't really have the answer I got
thinking that well if it is in fact it's
last one that we don't have established
methodology where can we find some and
how can we begin to explore how to
connect these two groups and the answer
kind of came to me during a product
development class that I was taking in
food science around the same time I
attended this Amy Harman seminar and
during this product development class we
talked about the typical product food
products development pipeline where it's
this really just kind of semi linear
product development scheme where it
starts off with exploratory of ideas and
concept development goes through a lot
of qualitative and quantitative
iterations and then involve lots of
different feedbacks from downstream
players including processors and
consumers and you get you
just have this really iterative complex
kind of interaction that somehow leads
to a prototype and eventually scaling up
and release of a new food product and I
saw a lot of parallels between a food
product development pipeline and a plant
breeding pipeline as well that we kind
of go through that same exploratory
trade concept identification we do our
population development prototype
development and then eventually get into
some of the early testing advanced
testing and eventually hopefully a
variety release as well and so I thought
that if we could see some parallels
between the food product development
pipeline and plant breeding pipeline
maybe we can use some of those tactics
and those methods that they use to in
the food product development pipelines
as a means of connecting with consumers
and so I connected with the sensor
evaluation center in the food science
department to begin exploring
established sensory analysis and
consumer marketing techniques that are
used commonly throughout the food
industry and once I began connecting
with the sensory evaluation center we
decided to actually perform a case study
using an establishment reading program
notably mine that we are in to see if
there was any methodology that we could
use on a more regular basis to connect
with consumers and one of the methods
that we settled on to begin exploring
was called qualitative multivariate
analysis and this is a well-established
product development tool that involves
eight different steps is really just
designed to expose the consumer and
participant to the product that you're
interested in a really interim intimate
setting so they become very familiar
with the product and can describe it
beyond just sensory modalities their
kind of initial marketing perspectives
so they get a really in-depth look at
the product that you're trying to
develop and so through the use of this
qualitative multivariate analysis also
NOAA's qma we're hoping to do is
understand the importance of different
plant traits through the consumer lens
to kind of begin to create a trait
hierarchy of sorts and then understand
what type of information we could draw
from consumers that would not only be
feasible to obtain for
greater but also applicable to a point
breeding program and then evaluate qma
as methodology in and of itself is this
a methodology that plant breeders would
want to use on a semi-regular basis in
the first place but most importantly and
probably the best part about this method
was that it would kind of use broad
strokes to talk to consumers and as such
really provided a lot of opportunity to
generate further hypotheses that we
could use in our breeding programs to
connect with consumers as well and so
this was a platform that we use
initially civ its began exploring the
relationship between plant breeders and
consumers so to get going we decided to
use a model crop of kale you haven't
heard it's a little trendy right now and
I guess I didn't pick it just because
it's kale in and of itself picked it
more because it has popularity and as
such consumer familiarity and just
provides a platform for conversation so
it's not necessarily just about the kale
so we I think's a little bit beyond that
but we had also the diversity of a
product set so we could go into our
breeding program and pick out six
different lines to give to consumers
that represented a diversity in the kale
product product category I guess you
could say so the six different types we
looked at work all word type Tuscan kale
one of our yellowish kind of breeding
lines a Portuguese trunk hyouta type
with thick mid ribs a classic deep curl
kale and then kind of a fist Iberian
kale as well and then once we had that
products that identified we decided to
bring on board 14 self-identified kale
enthusiasts that just means that they
were familiar with kale they prepared it
themselves and they liked it and they
were also creative and articulate and
that was really imperative in this
discussion because these participants
were bringing home these six different
Leaf types trying them out consuming
them and journaling about them and we
needed them to come back and be able to
provide feedback so we couldn't really
tap into a consumer base that didn't
like kale in the first place for this
this methodology but once we had our
our product set and our participants
identified we sent them home with these
six different leaf types and over the
course of two weeks the consumers
prepared these leaf types however they
liked and then they were required to
just journal about their experiences and
document their experiences through a
photo journal as well at the end of that
two weeks we brought all the consumers
back in for a facilitated focus group
this is a pretty intense three hour
session in which we picked apart every
emotion you could probably have
regarding kales purchasing and
consumption but throughout that we yes
as I said we mentioned we picked apart
associated motions we developed a
lexicon and did lexicon exercises to
kind of identify what consumers were
what words and descriptors consumers
were using to describe Kayle sensory
modalities and then we picked apart
contextual associations so were
different leaf types associated with
different culinary preparations we also
perform projective mapping exercises
which essentially just allowed the
participants to identify axes of
importance and then place those
different varieties along those axes in
order to identify relationships among
those different leaf types that makes
sense and all the information when we
took on this facilitated focus group was
used to build a value diagram a trait
hierarchy and then an online candle
survey which I'll talk about in a little
bit now walking out in this focus group
we ended up with a lot of qualitative
information which was kind of new
territory for me and a lot more of value
oriented and value descriptors and
emotions that I was expecting to but
some preliminary results that we got was
that there was a preconceived iconic
Kayle that was in art was already
defined in the consumers mind and that
was kind of this weepy curly kale type
and so that was kind of the current
market class that we were confined to
when we were were discussing kale so
trying to push the consumer definition
of a market class in the boundaries of
what a consumer is calling kale might be
difficult and so that some
that we need to consider when we go
about marketing or talking about some of
our diversity in our breeding program
consumers also emphasized the importance
of what we call freshness indicators so
how to have good store ability which
differentiates kale from a lot of other
leafy greens texture was extremely
important and the kale also needed to
retain its shape throughout a shape and
form throughout cooking and processing
as well I think perhaps one of the
biggest things that we got out of this
was that texture was one of the most
important sensory perceptions and
sensory modalities in the consumers mind
and our breeding program and not focus
on texture in the past we as I said were
inherently focused on aesthetics which
is the color and the shape of the of the
leaves and so moving forward we need to
be sure to identify if and we need to
focus on different texture traits as
well and then as I said we also got a
lot of value information from the
participants as well there's a strong
association with health well-being and
community and what you can do with all
this information and this is a bit of a
busy slide is begins to really identify
a value diagram and kind of understand
how what we do is plant breeders affects
larger core values in the consumer level
so we might adjust the texture component
whether that be the fibers fibrous myths
of a leaf but if we do so that must also
translate throughout the consumers
interaction with this kale type and so
it is important to keep this in mind and
important to inherently understand that
we can very much by making a menu and
semi small change to a leaf type affect
the ultimate identity and identification
of this product with a consumer as well
so moving forward I would say that qma
was really successful in in doing what
Amy Harmon called for which was could to
create an empathetic discussion with
consumers I wouldn't say that it was
necessarily the easiest methodology for
a plant breeder to engage with and I
think that we need to explore other new
methodologies to
but it was a start at least and then so
I'm going to continue to work with a
sensory evaluation center as I as I said
qma was a hypothesis generating platform
and we have a lot more to work with so
we're going to validate a lot of what we
saw in the focus group with an online
survey validated in-house over in the
food sensory evaluation center develop
lab protocols to develop to measure
texture quantitatively we're also in the
process of forming a descriptive panel
that we can go to with our breeding
lines to really evaluate some of these
sensory modalities on a consistent basis
and then we're also in the process of
developing a consumer kale sensory
descriptor wheel which will be really
interesting to run through our breeding
program as well all of this in the hopes
of continuing to support and integrative
plant breeding program and really
getting one step closer to connecting
plant breeders and consumers in the
future with that is one thing Kalina and
my advisor Phil Rufus for all their
support throughout this and I'm happy to
take any questions that you might have
or talk to you after you like
[Applause]
yeah so that's what we're working on so
I've got a summer scholar that uh will
be coming and that is hopefully what she
will be working on in conjunction with
the descriptive panel so you can set up
a descriptive panel who will be really
trained in identifying different
textural properties so you can rate a VP
type from a detector of a peanut-brittle
to peanut butter
basically but we want to validate that
in the lab using a penetrometer or
something else and so that's what we're
going to try to work on and see what's
the best best protocol so what is work
we couldn't have done this if we had a
panel that didn't like kale we wouldn't
any information out of them basically so
it was like it was fundamental that we
had to have a group of panelists that
consumed liked and consumed kale in the
first place however that's the ultimate
goal is to address the population that
doesn't like your product right and so
in the future when we introduce new
products we will have already have the
sensory modalities identified and
described for those different weave
types so once we give it to them we can
identify what has changed about those
lead types and if that affects the
perception from the people who don't
like it if that makes sense yeah
oh my bargain but specifically because
of congestion
so as far as I know the secondary
metabolites are relatively similar I
mean it's the same species as cabbage
and broccoli and cauliflower I don't I
don't know the answer what was animal
you could a medical excuse
I should include them all started
Medical subscription channel okay yeah
that'd be great that would be great
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu